i am captain america the mcu
has some amazing casting so much so that
some of the actors seem like they were
born for their role
for some of those in consideration that
didn't make the cut there would turn out
to still be some room for them elsewhere
in the mcu
sometimes their first audition acted as
a foot in the door
leading to them being considered for
another role in some cases
years later take a look at our list and
you'll appreciate just how carefully
marvel casts their movies
your savior is here
widely considered one of marvel's best
casting decisions
tom hiddleston does an amazing job as
loki
the part he actually auditioned for was
thor
they didn't think he had the right look
to play the god of thunder
but they immediately saw him as the god
of mischief
first tom was up for thor he did a
tremendous job but he wasn't thor
and the moment he came in and read
though though they couldn't have known
it at the time
tom would elevate the role and keep fans
coming back for more
it is amazing i i never expected it
black widow's time in the mcu came to a
close after an
entire decade and starring roles in
eight films including her own
but for another actress that was in the
running to play natasha romanov
her time is just beginning jolie may not
have made the final cut as black widow
but now she's thena in eternals as part
of phase 4.
with her background of action flicks and
incredible stunt work jolie is the
perfect fit for any superhero flick
really excited to be a part of the
family the winter soldier himself first
appeared on marvel's radar when he
auditioned for the part of captain
america he ended up being cast as steve
rogers best friend bucky instead
but it worked out beautifully stan has
actually said that he considers bucky to
be
a much better role than cap and his
dedication to the character
shows in his performance god i love this
place
bucky's place in the mcu has grown
because of it and he got to team up with
sam wilson for falcon and the winter
soldier
i feel very lucky another actress marvel
had considered to play black widow was
natalie portman who ended up playing
astrophysicist jane foster later on
know very well who you are oh you told
your dad about me
it might seem like portman got the
smaller part but her role is set to
expand in thor
love and thunder inspired by a storyline
from the comics while the mcu didn't do
much with jane foster in the first two
thor movies she will be taking up the
mantle of thor
bringing some much needed excitement to
the character
i love the movies that i've been a part
of while it might have been interesting
to see gyllenhaal as doctor strange
cumberbatch completely owns the role
with mastery over his comedic and tragic
angles
as well as the magical forces of the
universe gyllenhaal got to play a
different kind of magician as mysterio
in spider-man far from home and his
influence even set in motion the events
of spider-man
no way home jake pulled off the many
facets of quentin beck as master
manipulator
unhinged genius and creeper in the
background you only notice the second
time you watch the movie
despite not getting the role of drax
chadwick boseman made enough of an
impression
that he was one of the first actors that
came to mind when it came time to cast
the role of t'challa for captain america
civil war
and black panther i feel like that was
one of the moments when they were like
hey we can use him later
marvel's casting department made the
right call turning him down for drax
because his performance as the king of
wakanda was
incredible portraying the character's
passion and nobility in a way that will
never be forgotten
i am king of wakanda though he's no
longer with us
black panther wakanda forever is moving
forward and intends to pay tribute to
bozeman and his legacy
anthony mackie is probably glad he
didn't land the role of mandarin
which ended up going to ben kingsley it
left him open for a much bigger
more beloved and important role as sam
wilson starting out as falcon and taking
up the mantle as the new captain america
in falcon and the winter soldier there's
no denying that mackie landed a much
better role in the long run with a
bright future in the mcu
we need new heroes around
the time karen gillan was wrapping up
her time on doctor who
as the doctor's companion amy pond she
had had eyes on a spot in the mcu
while the role of sharon carter would go
to emily van camp
jillian would later end up being cast as
nebula in guardians of the galaxy
well hello boys she ended up being a
solid pick for her role
delivering on nebula's sharp and intense
personality
as well as showing her more vulnerable
side it's a good thing marvel decided to
go with a different chris
for captain america chris pratt's
comedic chops are definitely way better
suited to star-lord than steve rogers
plus if he had ended up playing cap we
might have missed out on his long run
on parks and rec as andy dwyer i have no
idea what i'm doing but i know i'm doing
it really really well
really being passed over to play the
star-spangled man
was a blessing his casting as peter
quill and guardians of the galaxy would
come just a few years later
before lupita nyong'o took on the role
of nakia in black panther
she was considered for the role of
nebula in the guardians of the galaxy
films
marvel's casting director sarah finn
called her insanely talented and said
she was quickly put into consideration
for a role in black
panther her involvement in other disney
projects like
the jungle book and star wars meant she
already had the connections and they
made good use of her talent
this was a hoorah moment for me
wyatt russell told good morning america
that his audition for steve rogers was
an experiment for him to see if he was
actually
any good at acting and doesn't think he
was ever in serious competition for the
role
fortunately for everybody there was no
chance and may ever play captain america
marvel must have seen something in him
however as a decade later he would end
up playing captain america
after all sort of in falcon and the
winter soldier
russell plays john walker the
replacement for captain america who
later becomes
u.s agent before being cast as eric
stevens
aka killmonger michael b jordan
auditioned for the role of sam wilson
killmonger may have only been in one
movie but we're glad we didn't miss out
on his iconic performance as the tragic
villain of black panther
kid from oakland running around
believing in fairy tales jordan
expressed to the daily beast that with
superheroes
a lot of those comics were created
before the 1960s
so they weren't going to have a black
man save america unfortunately limiting
the roles available to people of color
at least the mcu seems to be taking more
steps towards inclusivity with future
projects
it's hard to imagine anyone other than
robert downey jr in the role of tony
stark
there were other actors in the running
for consideration though including sam
rockwell
it's somewhat appropriate then that he
was cast as justin hammer in iron man 2
a character that is basically a knockoff
version of tony stark
he nails every note of hammer's try-hard
shallow personality and does a great job
of playing up those comedic notes in his
performance well it's more interesting
you know
and hey there's absolutely no shame
coming in second to rdj here
i'm not actually all that good rachel
mcadams who you will probably recognize
as regina george from mean girls ally
from the notebook or
irene adler in sherlock holmes nearly
ended up joining the mcu at the very
beginning
she was one of the names in the running
to play pepper potts all the way back
when the production for the first iron
man movie was gearing up
that role ultimately went to gwyneth
paltrow but
mcadams did end up playing an mcu love
interest 10 years later as dr christine
palmer and doctor strange
you know you just never know how that's
gonna play oscar isaac may not have
ended up playing the sorcerer supreme
but he was high up on the shortlist of
actors
marvel considered for the role marvel
must have still had their eye on isaac
as now he will be starring as the
titular character of the disney plus
show
moon knight aka mark spector the
backstory of moon knight has promising
prospects as a darker more mature side
of the marvel cinematic universe
and is doubtlessly an exciting project
to be a part of
it's a funny time and i think it's it's
not a time that anyone of us could have
imagined
do you think any of these actors would
have been better in the role they
auditioned for
for one last piece of casting trivia we
all know chris and liam hemsworth but
their other brother luke hemsworth
actually appeared in thor ragnarok
alongside chris
also playing thor he was the fake thor
in the asgardian stage play
depicting the event of thor the dark
world